to Downing Street from Parliament a
short distance but a long winding way to
win the keys to number 10 the first leg
tonight ten miles upriver from the
commons at Sky Studios on the way
passing through direct conservative
labour battle realms as you travel up
the temps it's clear they both have a
lot of work to do our next parliament
could be a multicolored tapestry of
smaller parties but Downing Street will
be occupied by one of the two men on the
south bank our first bellwether seat two
dozen cranes tower over from Battersea
conservative majority but labour
territory under Blair and brown the
cranes the physical embodiment of the
argument Mr Cameron will champion
tonight about a long-term economic plan
I think that what Cameron is saying is
correct I think there is recovery here
and only recovery I think there is
growth which is on top of that even
better than recovery but could add
Miliband not persuade you that he could
bring the cranes as well I mean he could
but at the moment he'd have to me or
more of what Cameron is saying but even
property developer Harry questions how
far the tide of recovery here reaches
obviously there's a reason why people
are investing their money here it's seen
as a safe haven a stable economy a
stable government stable laws because
you work here could you imagine could
you imagine buying and living in any of
these flats being built right now I
personally couldn't know Rhino quite
telling that isn't it yeah few miles to
the west Hammersmith just the sort of
place the Mr Cameron should be winning
off labor for a majority instead it was
labor that unseated the conservative
council last year and you don't even
have to reach trial and to hear echoes
of Mr Miliband's principal attack line
the future of the health service we're
from Sky News do you have any burning
issues you
to Miliband or Cameron I'm a medic and I
like I quite like see the NHS say as it
is so that's probably like Metis point
i'll be looking into what they say it
personally so you're looking for the NHS
to say is something them to invest in
operates go into private hands there's a
strong local campaign against hospital
closures here
in the race for number 10 David
Cameron's personal polling is lengths
ahead of his fellow Oxford graduate but
their parties are neck-and-neck our poll
of polls for national vote share a dead
heat thirty-four percent each our
projection for the House of Commons 278
for the Conservatives and 279 for labour
a very hung parliament with the SNP
holding the balance of power next up the
tightest of these seats brentford an
idol with
cruising underneath the Heathrow flight
path a seat that is conservative by just
2,000 votes and has voted with the
government of the day for over three
decades but now a challenge for both
men's attempts to woo the public we are
very close now to the venue for the
battle for number ten but you can see
why it is such a battle for the main
protagonists in this election even when
you meet people committed to one of the
two main parties there seems precious
little enthusiasm so it just might be
that these TV show cases are the
opportunity for ed miliband or David
Cameron to grab the selection here as
elsewhere uneasiness with the two main
parties is in the water camlin hasn't
done a bad job but I wouldn't be voting
for him and admitted burns the same I
wouldn't vote them because he's Unferth
inand at times not convinced me that
he's sincere I met Paul on the brentford
stretch of the river on his World War
Two relic houseboat he thinks down river
at Westminster they've lost it
definitely had broken relevant yeah push
comes to shove he could get your vote he
will get movo yeah yeah yeah but only
those by default in the facts
from the north bank of the Thames
tonight's battlefield Sky Studios a
skeptical nation waits for a game
changer it could come tonight faisal
Islam Sky News